[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous nouvelle semaine
d'information locale avec le 7-8 journal
sur tv soixante dix huit bienvenue dans
cette édition est les titres de ce lundi
6 novembre
un voyage de trois jours au coeur dalet
l'évêque de versailles et monseigneur
aumônier s'est rendu dans la cité
syrienne meurtri par quatre années de
conflit armé visite pour soutenir les
chrétiens d'orient notre invité à
participer à ce déplacement père yves
genou ville prêtres du diocèse de
versailles
c'est un classique depuis 2014 au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines le quatrième grand prix de
vélizy étaient au programme hier devant
lille spectateurs 140 coureurs y ont
participé dont de nombreux espoirs du
cyclisme sur piste français
et puis son film sort dans les salles ce
mois-ci l'humoriste belge aol madani
était à l'ugc skywest la semaine
dernière elle y présente et c'est tout
pour moi comédie largement inspiré de
son histoire personnelle pour débuter ce
journal les bons chiffres du logement en
ile de france cette année sur les douze
derniers mois
80 1600 nouveaux logements étaient mises
en construction augmentation de 23% par
rapport à l'an passé la région n'avait
pas autant construit depuis 40 ans selon
le préfet de région michel cadot
évolution positive rendue possible par
le nombre croissant de permis de
construire octroyés dans le département
francilien + 24 % dans les yvelines à
titre d'exemple c'est la première fois
qu'un évêque français se rend à alep
depuis la fin des combats monseigneur
éric aumônier était en visite dans la
ville syrienne du 23 au 26 octobre
dernier et déplacements de l'évêque de
versailles dans une cité largement
détruite après quatre ans de guerre
bonsoir père yves nos villes bonsoir
vous êtes prêtre du diocèse de
versailles et assistants ecclésiastique
de l'aide à l'église en détresse france
aux côtés du directeur de cette
fondation marc fromager
vous avez accompagné le monseigneur
aumônier dans ce voyage trois jours pour
soutenir les chrétiens de syrie on va
revenir sur cette visite dans un instant
première question quelle richesse
intérieure ce voyage vous at il apporté
voilà vous personnellement qu'est ce que
vous en retenez alors d'abord je sais la
rencontre sur place de ces chrétiens
dorian ces chrétiens qui sont restés à
l'est puis qui ont vécu ces quatre cinq
six ans de guerre et qui ont gardé alors
il ne cache pas qu'il ya eu des années
très difficiles où toute la ville était
sans électricité sans chauffage peu
d'eau même si les quartiers entiers
d'alep ont été peu touchés il ya des
quartiers par contre qu'ils ont été
totalement ravagées et on le sait la
partie est la partie s le front le
centre-ville qui a été détruit autour de
la citadelle par des ch et en même temps
on sent chez ces chrétiens une très
grande ferveur
en tout cas une espérance une espérance
sur cette période qui débute aujourd'hui
puisque depuis le mois de décembre à fin
décembre les conflits en tant que sont
arrêtés même si tout n'est pas sécurisé
le soir on entend encore quelques bruits
d'armes
mais voilà on sent bien dans une
dimension dans une dynamique qui
aujourd'hui positive et qui est marquée
par une grande attente et a écrit ces
chrétiens d'alep ce qui l attend du
retour de tous ceux qui pour de
multiples raisons tout à fait justifiée
ont dû fuir à l'aide d'un tiers des
chrétiens d'alep qui ont la rue
aujourd'hui autour de 30 milles avec
certains qui sont déjà revenus
ils étaient 150 milles au début du
conflit est-ce que se rendre sur place a
été difficile et comment finalement ce
voyage at il été rendue possible alors
le créateur du possible parce que là une
aide à l'église en détresse nous
n'aidons il nous sommes très présents
moyen-orient en syrie nous avons dépensé
18 millions en cinq ans pour aider et
permettre chrétiens de rester sur place
dans la mesure du possible et donc nous
avons un certain nombre de contacts sur
place qui n'ont permis sous voyage et
qui ont permis de le faire dans des
conditions sécuritaires acceptable sans
prendre de risques inutiles et donc
c'est ce qui a permis de le faire et
c'était très important aussi pour notre
et des consignes aux aumôniers puisque
le carmel d'alep est jumelé
spirituellement avec le diocèse de
versailles de pouvoir sur place à les
remercier prendre un temps de prière un
peu gratuit d'ailleurs très grave y avec
les religieuses dahleb c7 carmélites qui
ont passé toute la guerre
au coeur de cette ville meurtrie cet
important est de leur rendre hommage le
rendre visite sur place tout à fait de
pouvoir manifester aussi que mais même
pour nous la halle à l'union de la
prière la coupe de la prière n'est pas
que quelque chose d'un peu fou evans
mais parfois passe par les actes très
concret alors ce déplacement je les dis
s'est déroulée dix mois après la fin de
la guerre quatre ans de conflit armé qui
avec la veille des bombardements quasi
quotidiens contre les djihadistes mais
aussi contre l'autre partie et dhaleh
blessés rebelles au régime de bachar el
assad
les affrontements ont fait trente mille
morts c'est une ville fantôme que vous
avez trouvé surprises et des quartiers
qui sont totalement fantôme
il ya des quartiers qui sont totalement
détruits au s'aperçoit et en même temps
alors pour ceux qui voient là qu'ils ont
pu côtoyer des théâtres de guerre ont ça
peut être une aucune ville n'est jamais
totalement détruits il ya des quartiers
où ont été peu touchés parce que c'était
pas sur le front parce que c'était la
partie dite loyalistes d'alep et donc
qu'ils n'avaient pas de raison
particulière d'être touchés est-ce qu'on
n'oserait imaginer que avant avant ce
conflit à lettres c'était la capitale
économique de la série 3 millions
d'habitants des trésors millénaire on
imagine sa surprise quand on voit le
sens très bien que c'est une ville qui
qui qui qui a eu qu'à us en son son
rayonnement puis un centre ville
historique
on voit quand même des marques de la
présence forêt française avant la guerre
avant la guerre de 45 on va donc on va
très bien dès que c'est une blague c'est
une ville qui a vécu c'est une ville qui
a énormément de possibilités et alors
aujourd'hui faute ou relancer il faut
tout reconstruire
et d'ailleurs ce qui est impressionnant
c'est que ça va très vite les rues sont
débiles déblayer on s'aperçoit que même
la route pour aller de damas à alep et
parfaitement reconstruite d'accord elle
est sécurisée dans tout le nord mais
elle est parfaitement reconstruit donc
on se sent que il ya cette volonté le
souk à redémarrer au même endroit à
l'est puisque l'endroit du sou qui était
dans la ville historique il a été l'un
des 13 ans et voilà où ça passe aucun
endroit où la soul a redémarré
on sort vraiment cette volonté est en
fait tout le défi d'être des mois à
venir va être là est ce que les
chrétiens
moi je dis est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
revenir concrètement mais ce qui booste
y en avoir la force
après tout ce qui a été vécu toutes les
blessures intérieures complète
vécue par ceux qui étaient sur place et
ça ils sont les seuls à pouvoir prendre
la décision nous nous devons les aider
leur donner les moyens de pouvoir vivre
ce choix c'est ça j'allais vous relancez
justement sur la suite maintenant à quoi
va vous servir ce voyage en france
peut-être témoigner aussi est d aider
ces chrétiens sur place alors en france
témoigne essais et puis c'était très
important pour les chrétiens sur place
que rapidement nous l'avions sur place
et puis pour nous l'un des buts en
détresse l'importance aussi maintenant
c'est de voir quelles vont être les
priorités dans les chantiers de
reconstruction que ça soit contraitement
d'église de logements de centres
d'apprentis l'on n'a visité un centre
d'apprentis qui était mise en place par
l'église
melkite catholique d'alep pour tout de
suite repéré m aux jeunes d'avoir une
formation très concrète électricien de
charpentier de menuse esta pour très
vite relancer l'activité sur place et
sécrétant on peut les aider aussi
concrètement on peut faire un don alors
concrètement bien sûr on peut faire un
don à le dé l'aide à l'église en
détresse suffit de taper sur google a eu
des aides à l'église en est le 6 affiche
actuellement voilà
et puis aussi peut-être alors peu je me
permet de montrer un livre
que marc roger que le directeur de l'afd
a écrit qui permet aussi de comprendre
les enjeux de cette crise syrienne et
aussi les espérances de cette crise
syrienne et moyen-orient de manière plus
large
merci tu arrives génome d'un porc est
avec nous merci beaucoup je m'appelle
vous êtes prêtre du diocèse de
versailles également assistant
ecclésiastique de la fondation aide à
l'église en détresse france la fondation
qui a donc accompagné à monseigneur
aumônier dans ce voyage à alep en syrie
économie maintenant avec cette success
story saint-quentinoise l'entreprise
asmodée est implantée à vue en cours
depuis plus de 20 ans elle ne cesse de
se développer à l'international en
témoignent ses créations jungle speed ou
encore time's up et des jeux de société
que l'on ressort volontiers lors de
repas en famille ou de soirées entre
amis
reportage de l'ird au rayon des cartes
représentant une petite créature jaune
chargé d'électricité ou encore un totem
en bois attraper le plus vite possible
voici deux exemples de jeux qui ont fait
et font encore le succès de la société
yvelinoise à ce mode est implantée à
guyancourt l'entreprise qui pèse 400
millions d'euros en 2017 emploie plus de
600 personnes à travers le monde avec
une forte présence en europe
aujourd'hui samedi 10 pays européens
dans lequel on est présent les plus
importants angleterre allemagne belgique
espagne italie et puis les pays
nordiques
le tout dernier est en italie c'est le
reste marché encore le plus lu
plus solide le plus ancien si le plus
donc plus mature pour nous dire ces
trois quarts du chiffre du groupe se
ferait en entrant sur leur banc depuis
plus de 20 ans à ce mode est distribuée
édite des jeux de société des jeux de
cartes mais aussi des jeux d'ambiance
comme time's up ou encore perudo très
apprécié d'ailleurs par plusieurs
joueurs de l'équipe de france de
football
un catalogue qui comprend plus de 2000
références et qui fait d'asmodée le
leader des jeux de société en france
son ambition aujourd'hui conquérir le
monde
je vais marais le marché n'a qu en 2006
j'étais parti là bas donc aujourd'hui on
a encore beaucoup de travail à faire là
bas mais on n'a jamais une forte
posséder de dévolution une croissance
sur les états unis
on a développé un bureau en chine qui
est un marché émergent sur le jeu un peu
compliqué culturellement et ses
structures de discrétion bien
différentes mais on apprend
tranquillement mais sûrement être
innovant trouvait toujours les meilleurs
produits
voilà le secret d'asmodée qui lui a
permis d'afficher une croissance à deux
chiffres ces dernières années un
deuxième invité marc joindre au plateau
il est devenu le nouveau président de l'
agence technique départementale
ingéniérie bonsoir philippe benassaya
soit vous êtes le maire de bois d'arcy
conseil départemental et donc président
à d'ingéniérie depuis début octobre vous
avez succédé à alain schmitz élu
sénateur
on verra dans un instant comment vous
aborder ce nouveau rôle et et quelles
sont vos perspectives pour la suite
d'abord présentons et ingénierie pour
les téléspectateurs
les téléspectateurs qui ne connaissent
pas cette agence c'est une structure qui
dépend du conseil départemental des
yvelines et c'est un vrai outil pour
pour les communes rurales du département
oui tout d'abord les yvelines c'est un
fantastique département rural avec un
patrimoine extraordinaire qui fait le
bonheur des touristes et même des
habitants et des riverains illinois donc
le département investit énormément dans
l'investissement rurale parce que 90 %
des communes i vi nations dans un
secteur rural
c'est important de venir en aide
investir pour la ruralité exactement ce
qui est en reprenant prenons un exemple
quand vous avez des petites communes de
100 ou 200 habitants qui ont un budget
de 200 mille euros par exemple 150000
euros par an lorsqu'il doit faire des
rénovations de bâtiments publics
d'assainissement de voirie qui coûte 50
ou 100 mille euros c'est obligé qui part
donc il faut venir en aide à ces assez
commune et ingénierie est là pour
d'abord mettre en rapport
toutes les personnes qui passent de tdc
commune l'accord mais également en
assistance à maîtrise d'ouvragé
ce qu'est le ski et le l'objectif
d'ingénierie dans la voirie dans
l'assainissement dans le bâtiment public
ça peut des lavoirs ça peut être plein
d'autres choses et c'est ça qui fait la
beauté des yvelines c'est que le
département ne lâche pas ce secteur est
investi énormément dans l'est dans la
ruralité monter finalement clairement
oui ces projets d'investissement en
respectant le l'aspect financier
l'aspect économique se sont fait
financier économique et également c'est
également le rôle de d'ingénierie dans
la sauvegarde du patrimoine et voilà
pourquoi c'est justement j'avais ou
relancer là dessus important de venir en
aide à ces communes rurales finalement à
quelles difficultés sont elles
confrontées au quotidien pour pouvoir
justement venir enfin investir c'est le
budget je me rasais le budget c'est
c'est déjà le le premier le premier
secteur je suis moi même et lui d'un
canton le canton bois d'arcy saint cyr
l'école qui a une partie rurale avec des
villes comme chavenay rémoulins rennes
moulin ses 112 habitants je crois que
c'est un peu plus cent mille euros de
budget annuel
comment fait-il le maire pour pouvoir
investir et bien ceux qui se tournent
vers différents partenaires dont
notamment le département via ingénierie
pour pouvoir refaire un pont
créer des buses pour éviter des
inondations je ne sais pas paver la rue
principale du village rénové l'avoir
créé une salle des fêtes une salle
associative ingénierie investi dans ce
genre de projet la danse a fait vivre le
tissu rural est également le tissu
quotidien des gens c'est ça qui est
important
vous en avez évoqué plusieurs exemples
du coup plusieurs types de projets
d'investissements peuvent être remontée
avec l'aide d'ingénieurs et
assainissement voirie bâtiments publics
restauration du patrimoine également du
patrimoine dont je parlais c'est une des
nouvelles activités d'ingénierie
c'est l'avenir également d'un générique
que d'investir dans la restauration du
patrimoine
alors vous avez été nommé président en
octobre après une élection comme maire
de bois d'arcy en 2014 comme conseiller
départemental en 2015 comment on aborde
ce nouveau re comment abordez vous ce
nouveau rôle de président d'ingénierie
alors tout d'abord c'est vrai qu'en tant
que maire et conseil départemental je
suis plutôt acteurs dans le domaine de
tout ce qui est urbaniste mme patrimoine
et
investissement aménagement du territoire
16 à bord mais ce qui est local voilà
comme je suis également président du cae
présent du con seil architectural et
urbain des yvelines
la volonté de pierre bédier le président
du département c'était de créer un
véritable pôle à la fois aménagements
patrimoine et ruralité et donc si vous
permettez l'expression je coiffe un
petit peu les deux c'est à dire le seuil
a eu un générique je coiffe un petit peu
tout ce domaine départemental c'est une
vraie passion aussi un sens ça démarre
d'une passion et puis ça se traduit
également par maintenant des
responsabilités importantes
vous avez l'occasion de prendre la
température très vite vous avez par
exemple animé une table ronde ruralité
lors de l'université des maires des
yvelines s'est aussi début octobre ça
vous a permis de rencontrer des maires
oui d'abord c'est une table ronde qui
était là était un vrai un vrai succès
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de maires
delà de la zone rurale ça m'a permis de
me présenter aussi de nouer des contacts
de rassurer aussi parce qu'on ya
toujours un changement de président il
faut aussi il faut aussi montrer ce
qu'on veut faire et être fidèle
également à l'héritage
donc ça c'était également une très très
bonne prise de pouls de la zone rurale
lors de cette conférence les dernières
minutes de cet entretien très rapidement
maintenant vos priorités pour pour les
mois à venir pour les semaines à venir
quelles perspectives
alors tout d'abord moi je veux rester au
contact du terrain comme l'a fait alain
schmitt dans l'oubli dans le passé c'est
très important de rencontrer les maires
faut savoir que lorsque les petits
maires jeudi petit maire puisque petite
commune bien sûr petit maire voit
arriver ingénérie c'est important pour
eux parce que c'est le début d'une
solution
et puis également nous allons nous
installer à rambouillet donc dans la
capitale même de la ruralité des
yvelines donc c'est aussi important
d'être au sein même du territoire rural
on a déménagé de versailles rambouillet
et puis on va également s'étendre au
niveau au niveau du personnel on va
passer de 10 à 15 personnes
donc on est en plein air en pleine
restructuration évolution et ça c'est
très important de faire partie de cette
aventure
merci philippe benassaya braqué avec
nouveau président de l' agence technique
départementale ingénierie et pour plus
d'informations vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran et du sport maintenant la
quatrième édition du grand prix de
belize i se tenait hier au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
hymne au programme de l'événement est
dédiée au cyclisme sur piste plusieurs
disciplines j'en perds mon oreillette
140 coureurs étaient de la partie dont
de jeunes pousses de la discipline
compétition qui a rassemblé près de 1000
spectateurs on voit ce avec nicolas
landry du spectacle sur la piste du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour cette quatrième édition du grand
prix de vélizy frédéric est venu avec
son frère et son fils pour regarder les
champions c'est la première fois que je
venais au vélodrome j'ai souvent eu
l'occasion
souvent l'on a envie de venir mais
jamais eu l'occasion de devenir le
vélodrome c'est quelque chose de
sympathique de nouveau pour moi
et
et c'est vrai que c'est impressionnant
voix c'est rempl on se demande comment
on peut tenir dessus pour tenir sur la
rampe les pistards se prépare à l'effort
c'est le cas de guillaume sous terre
engagés sur la course par élimination
le principe tous les deux tours le
cycliste arrivé en dernier est éliminé
une épreuve remportée par guillaume je
suis content parce que toujours plaisir
de gagner surtout qu'il ya quand même du
niveau et je me suis bien fait mal aux
pattes victoire au bout scratch vitesse
par équipes tempo différentes
disciplines du cyclisme sur piste de la
catégorie shon à seniors masculines et
féminines venant de différentes régions
c'est un révélateur de jeunes talents
faut pas oublier que à la première
édition nous avions laurie berton
quentin lafargue nous avions benjamin
thomas morgan kneisky qui sont tous en
équipe de france et qui sont devenus
champions du monde lui est déjà champion
du monde catégorie junior vitesse
individuelle à 18 ans rien n'est là l'a
rejoint le pôle france
il a participé à l'épreuve de keirin
huit tours dont 6 effectué derrière la
moto avant un sprint final remporté par
le jeune espoir
le pistard de vélizy yens dujarrier est
arrivé 3e pas je tiens le jour
passé derrière j'ai tout de suite vu que
béria j'avoue ne pas trop prendre la
tête ne suis pas je reste en tête et
j'étais vigilants derrière super content
j'avais j'ai tiré le bon le bon numéro
juste dans la roue du jeu pose du monde
j'ai juste essayé de conserver sa à sa
roue je suis resté dedans et avec le
boîtier que j'avais une miss j'ai réussi
même à pouvoir ré accélérer sur sur la
dernière ligne droite
deuxième manche de cette compétition au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le dimanche 26 novembre départ hier
depuis le port du havre direction
salvador de bahia au brésil 2 yvelinois
sont parmi les 74 keeper en lice dans la
transat jacques vabre la course de voile
transatlantique en duo le versaillais
tanguy de lamotte fait équipe avec
samantha davies une nouvelle fois pour
initiative coeur sa course va servir à
récolter des fonds pour sauver un
maximum d'enfants malades du coeur
le bateau imoca d'ailleurs été baptisée
par le spationaute thomas pesquet enfin
le deuxième coureur du département est
originaire de rambouillet louis burton
engagé avec sa femme servane escoffier
pour bureau vallée également en
catégorie imoca à versailles les curieux
et passionnés de littérature ainsi que
d'histoires sont servis la bibliothèque
municipale propose des visites guidées
insolites du bâtiment un parcours et des
secrets à découvrir avec nicolas landry
et les arrêts ch
attention parce que c'est là qu'on rende
enfin c'est là qu'ils nous entrons dans
notre petit labyrinthe la famille moutou
et transportés à travers les époques
lors des deux heures de visite guidée
dans les murs de la bibliothèque
municipale de versailles
ici sont conservées plus de 700 mille
ouvrages en plus ou moins en bon état
mais s'ils cachent aussi des tableaux et
des sculptures car le bâtiment est un
ancien musée la visite insolite permet
de présenter diverses époques diverses
pièces patrimoniale
l'idée c'est de montrer que le parcours
épouse un peu l'histoire particulière de
ce bâtiment qui est l'ancien hôtel des
affaires étrangères de la marine et que
la bibliothèque un peu à peu colonisé ce
haut lieu de l'histoire de france a
également été le témoin de traités
internationaux
évidemment vous êtes dans le bâtiment où
a été signé alors pas signé mais
élaborer le traité d'indépendance des
états unis
donc les américains ont toujours sûrs
d'y conduire une certaine amitié
les avis de versailles la visite
s'adapte à tous les publics et regorge
d'anecdotes qui passionne les grands
comme les petits
il faut savoir que nous avons hérité
tout à fait légalement par par notaire
d'un fantôme
oui d'ailleurs ce monsieur un nom il
s'appelle monsieur lance la suite par
dont des photos c'est une photo mais si
tu l'as laissé un mot donc on verra
revue historique bulletin roman ou
encore périodiques les sous-sols
révèlent leurs richesses qui passionne
tant les visiteurs
nous on aime beaucoup les livres de
petits moins exceptionnel les livres en
fait trop strass toute une histoire et
je trouve qui est souvent méconnu
les visites insolites vous donne rendez
vous sur inscription tous les samedis
matins elle nous vient de belgique a été
révélée en france par le jamel comedy
club l'humoriste nawel madani s'essaye
au cinéma après plusieurs one woman show
elle était à saint quentin en yvelines
la semaine dernière pour présenter c'est
tout pour moi
son premier film à la réalisation marie
à pannetrat et mélanie poquet
accueil chaleureux pour nawal madani
l'humoriste présentait son tout premier
film à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est tout pour moi raconte l'histoire
d'une jeune bruxelloise une fiction
autobiographique 1995 bruxelles à droite
c'est moi lilas et ce alors dès le début
des ennuis
j'ai pas hésité à aller chercher dans
mon histoire personnelle de temps en
temps à aller puiser dans des événements
qui me sont réellement arrivé puis et
puis et puis parfois fictionné parce que
c'est compliqué de de raconter sa propre
histoire
je voulais prendre un recul et puis
surtout qu'il ya des périodes de ma vie
qui ont été beaucoup plus longue dans la
galère 12 ans de galère je fais déchirer
vos passeports
je vais vous envoyer aux blettes j'ai ma
mère et vous allez faire d'humour sur
les cactus mais quinze ans après j'étais
toujours à fond j'avais qu'une idée en
tête a tenté ma chance à paris
[Musique]
une première expérience derrière et
devant la caméra vu un premier film pour
l'artiste belge comme pour la plupart du
casting est toujours aussi vous voulez
que les gens puissent se projeter
s'identifier c'est un lourd challenge et
parce que j'ai eu cinq semaines pour
tourner ce film là
les journées étaient intensive on a
tourné sept minutes jour du film c'est
très laid c'est le rythme d'un téléfilm
il y avait beaucoup de décors beaucoup
personnage il fallait qu'on s'attache
aux personnages secondaires autant très
propre d'autant que les personnages
principaux
c'est tout pour moi sera dans les salles
le 29 novembre prochain
le film parle de danse de one man show
mais c'est aussi une histoire d'amour et
celui de sa famille une succès story
pour un message
toujours prêt à penser
nous sentons quoi est ce que vous êtes
[Musique]
et puis avant de refermer ce journal on
les aime les plats chauds à base de
fromage reviennent à la mode avec les
températures a qui se font de plus en
plus basses une bonne raclette fondue ou
encore tartiflette le fromage les
français en raffolent 65% en consomment
de façon quotidienne et ce restaurant de
versailles en a fait sa spécialité
marylène yapi cheminots et nicolas
landry
qu'est ce qui vous ferait plaisir au
menu dans ce restaurant de versailles du
fromage la star des plats d'hiver s'est
faufilé dans chaque main présent à la
carte de l'entrée jusqu'au dessert
le principe de ce restaurant c'est de
mêler à la fois des fromages connu de
france avec des plats également gaulle
ils vont faire un petit mélange est de
rester sera le thème principal les
fromages un filet mignon sault saint
félicien un pavé de saumon rôti ou saint
maur à chaque viande sa sauce fromagère
et pour les plus grands amateurs le
plateau permet une dégustation des
arrivages du jour ce qui par fais tes
frais c'est très bon et en plus cela la
déclinaison des fromages de plus en plus
fort c'est une très bonne idée des
fromages forts mais aussi plus léger
avec au moins 1200 variétés de fromages
produits en france
le consommateur a du choix les réticents
au caractère et à l'auteur du maroilles
peuvent trouver saveurs à leur palais
c'est vrai que moi même je suis pas très
fromage
j'ai un peu de mal avec ceux qui sont
assez fort mais honnêtement dans je
trouve ça très sympa eu le petit plat
que mon
mon beau père a pris avec la déclinaison
fromage effectivement ça vaut le coup
les français sont les plus gros
consommateurs de fromages au monde avec
en moyenne 25 kg par habitant chaque
année ils sont fiers de leur terroir qui
s'exporte 35% de la production française
est consommé à l'étranger c'est quand
même un de nos plus importants produits
pour la gastronomie fromages français
est quand même réputés sur le podium des
fromages préféré des français
les mental ou vendu à 146 mille tonnes
par an suivi du camembert et du coup
l'onu à consommer bien sûr avec
modération c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal le replay les reportages sont à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tablette tv 78
très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]